The public is of the view that we should
get out of Iraq and be,
we should be very careful about the use
of force or our resources are stressed,
stretched.
We just have had a bad experience in
though that always,
that always tends to sour people and the
use of force.
But if you look at the way Americans
feel about the legitimacy of using
military force as a way of dealing with
international problems,
it's much stronger than it is in many
parts of Europe.
It is a,
there's still more support in the United
States for preemptive war,
even given disillusionment with Iraq
than there is among our European allies.
So,
um,
to ensure that Americans are sort of
down on war right now.
Uh,
but the public has a very Jacksonian
view of,
uh,
of,
um,
uh,
of the use of military force generally
their los to do things but hurt us or
threaten us and we'll go at you.
Uh,
but the public is also very pragmatic
when things aren't working,
they want out and they don't want to see
a American lives wasted.
Well,
not strictly,
but certainly the influence of public
opinion on you can't conduct a war
without public support in the long run.
That's what that was.
The message of Vietnam and the pressure
to get troops out of it,
get some sense that we're on our way
out.
His very great and,
uh,
I don't think it will be the only
factor,
but it's one factor in the way.
Uh,
uh,
Iraq will play on
the.